tick tock's got a lifespan they're not
going to be around forever tick tock's
got a lifespan you got a year two years
one Republican president away from Tick
Tock being banned in America and you're
going to be the next Vine and some
people who are not ready for it they're
not going to be adjusting it's already
done yeah you think so yeah YouTube
shorts yeah that's the beautiful thing
about like about uh This is Gonna sound
[ __ ] up but kind of like when like
government and uh social media companies
are in bed with each other I mean you
know the game probably better than
anybody but I would assume once your
company gets big enough the government
goes hey now we work together
and then you go okay it's kind of like a
mafia yeah
but it's like you've reached escape
velocity and now we work together and so
with YouTube shorts It's the exact same
thing as Tick Tock if you look at it
right only it has way more data and way
more American data you're talking about
YouTube which is Google right these are
the numbered one and two search engines
in the world there's no way that you
would prefer to be on Tick Tock than you
would be on YouTube